[موسيقى]
رامي منور في جده للمراه قبل
جدا
من الناس اللي كانت اما كنت بساله في
الاول وكلمني على اول الحفله ليه في
السعوديه فبقول له انا ما اعرفش انا ليا
جمهور هنا ولا لا قال لي انت هتتخض اول
مره
فخلاص بقى بالنسبه لي كلمه السعوديه بيجي
في بالي فورا وبيجي في بالي حمزه وبيبقى
فيها الخير بالنسبه لي
محتاجه اركز واذاكر لان السوق بيتغير كل
يوم الترنداد بتتغير كل يوم كل يوم بيطلع
موضه مزيكا جديده وانا بصفتي ملحن ومطرب
لازم اذاكر علشان ما ينفعش ابقى متواجد
وخلاص انا طموحي ابقى بعد عمر طويل من
الناس اللي سابت علامه في المزيد اكتر
خدعه وانك انت تركز على الفتره الجايه خط
معين في الاغاني اسم معين تشتغل معاه اكثر
حاجه مركز عليه هو كده كده الاغاني لازم
يبقى كلام حلو والتوزيع حلو
الخطه اللي انا هعملها ان شاء الله من بعد
رمضان كل اسبوعين اغنيه الى ما لا نهايه
من الفنان اللي الفتره الجايه انت مصر انه
لازم اتعاون معاه احد لسه ما سايب بس مصر
ده هدف ان الفتره اللي فاتت دي اشتغلت كل
اللي اشتغلته معاهم كانوا بقره بس اخر
فتره دي في عاجبني جدا اثنين ملحنين محمود
انور واحمد العبد دول بالنسبه لي
انك تغني لهم مش بس شاطرين هما دايما
عارفه لما في عندي انا كملحن زمان لما كنت
بعمل اغنيه كنت بقى عندي مثلا حماقي عايز
اديها له هم عندهم رمي زين يديها له ونروح
دي مهمه جدا وانا محتاج اخدها منهم
[موسيقى]
يا حبيبتي نفسي